herr präsident geschätzte kollegen in
gärten gäste der junge noch mal ganz
kurz auf ihre sprache zum
vermittlungsausschuss sie wollen die
leute nicht mitnehmen herr jung ist sie
wollen sie aufnehmen mit dem die top 25
in madrid ist vorbei die klima karawane
zieht weiter
aber welches wichtige ereignis hat den
tatsächlich den letzten wochen
stattgefunden richtig dass man die
unterhauswahlen in großbritannien
boris johnson hat einen erdrutschsieg
erzielt und die briten haben sich damit
ganz klar gegen die eu entschieden
chancen hatte war hilfe von unerwarteter
seite
während der un klimakonferenz nämlich
stellte uhr eu-kommissionspräsident in
von allein ihren sogenannten green deal
vor und gab den briten das entscheidende
signal rette sich wer kann
first exit dieser green deal wird keine
mutlangen werden sondern es wird der
moment des harten aufschlag ist der ihm
auf dem boden der realität
doch zurück nach deutschland hier soll
der kohle als form der energieerzeugung
der rücken gekehrt werden
aber nach der mehrfach wollte von
ausstieg und wieder einstieg und
wiedereinstieg zum wieder ausstieg aus
der kernenergie
da war es nicht wind und sonne es war
einzig und allein die kohle die dafür
gesorgt hat in deutschland das die
lichter nicht ausgehen
nun sollen aber zahlen kommen wir gleich
nach der empfehlung des sogenannten
kohle kommission bis ende 20 22 12 5
gigawatt kohlestrom vom netz gehen
zusätzlich zu den 9,5 gigawatt an
nuklearer leistungen die bis ende 2022
ebenfalls ebenfalls vom netz gehen
werden
das sind somit 22 gigawatt mehr als ein
viertel der spitzenlast für deutschland
für dieses unterfangen bleibt nur noch
drei jahre zeit
grund genug einmal zu schauen wie diese
leistung ersetzt werden kann
die regierung wird ja nicht müßig uns zu
erklären dass dies mittels sogenannter
erneuerbare energien also sonne und wind
gelingen wird formal haben wir zwar 60
gigawatt einwintern ca 50 gigawatt an
solarleistung installiert
das klingt erst mal ausreichend aber
diese leistungen stehen ja nicht
konstant zur verfügung weil der wind
nicht immer weht und die sonne natürlich
nicht immer scheint in mittel steht wind
circa 20 prozent derzeit zur verfügung
bei sonne sind es magere zehn prozent
auf 10 60 gigawatt werden dann 12 und
aus den 50 werden 5 gb zusammen 17
gigawatt
das heißt im mittel stehen uns der
kompensation von 22 gigawatt nur
ungenügende 17 gigawatt sogenannte
erneuerbare zur verfügung das reicht
hinten und vorne nicht und da haben sie
auch nichts ändern denn trotz eeg denn
trotz eeg und andere zwangsmaßnahmen hat
der aufbau dieser mageren 17 gigawatt
fast 20 jahre gedauert und über 300
milliarden euro verschwendet
das wird in den kommenden drei jahren
auch nicht besser werden weil ja immer
mehr winden aus der umlage fallen und
dann permanent still gelegt werden und
ich hatte es ihnen an dieser stelle in
den letzten vergangenen woche gesagt das
ist keine vernünftige energiepolitik das
ist sozialistische mangel wird
achtung
und wir haben jetzt auch nur die
mittlere verfügbarkeit betrachtet das
problem der aktuellen verfügbarkeit von
strom ist hier noch gar nicht beleuchtet
worden
und das sind noch viel viel düsterer aus
und das beste am wichtigen punkt liebe
unionsfraktion
das erneuerbare energien gesetzt haben
wir ihnen zu beraten
jaja beschlossen wurde es zwar unter
rot-grün aber es gibt ein 14 jahre zeit
gehabt diesen politischen unsinn zu
beenden und passiert ist das nicht weil
auch sie sich ein kleines grünes
mäntelchen umhängen wollen aber aber
liebe union handlungen haben
konsequenzen es ist nicht möglich die
art und weise wie wir energie gewinnen
grundlegend umzukrempeln ohne dass dies
folgen für die bürger hat
dies ändert sich auch dann nicht wenn
sie das seit jahren wie ein mantra vor
sich her beten wenn sie die
energiewirtschaft
von einer funktionierenden
stromerzeugung die sich daran orientiert
so viel strom wie benötigt wird zu
erzeugen dahingegen transformieren zu
einer unzuverlässigen stromerzeugung bei
der man halt irgendwie mit dem klar
kommen muss was gerade zur verfügung
steht
dann hat das selbstverständlich massive
auswirkungen auf den geldbeutel und die
art und weise der bürger zu leben eine
auswirkung
sie wissen dass sie wissen das aber dass
sie streuen die bürger sand in die augen
weiß natürlich genau wissen dass er ihre
politik abstrafen wert wenn er hinter
ihren poetischen energie dörfer liegt
erreicht haben sie eigentlich auch
nichts klimaziele 2020 nicht erreicht
eine million e-autos auf unsere straßen
nicht erreicht strom einsparziele 2020
nicht erreicht einsparziele beim
primärenergieverbrauch nicht erreicht
senkung des energieverbrauchs im verkehr
nicht erreicht nicht erreicht nicht
erreicht ungenügend sechs sätzen und
dass sie ihn schon jetzt dass sie heute
selbst noch eine solche aktuelle stunde
zu ihrem versagen fordern ist ein
bisschen dreist und ein bisschen frech
einen punkt haben sie allerdings leider
recht hätten deutschland bleibt auf kurs
aber leider fehlen uns ihr kurz direkt
in den abgrund auf kosten unserer
wirtschaft auf kosten der steuerzahler
und auf kosten hunderttausende deutsche
arbeitsplätze sehr deutliche kritik von
rainer kraft von der fdp fraktion